let's break down how much money Harry
and Megan will walk away from in order
to see quote financial independence they
are going to give up the money that
British taxpayers give to the Queen now
that only amounts to about five percent
of their household expenditure the
remaining ninety five percent is paid
for by the Prince of Wales and that
income isn't going to stop because
they're stepping down as senior members
of the royal family but it's going to be
something that will be addressed if
they're going to be financially
independent how are they going to do
that and not face accusations that
they're cashing in on their royal status
so how will they continue to earn income
while many on Twitter hope Megan will
play herself on a future season of the
crown here are some likely scenarios
they can make millions off of a book
deal because everybody wants to know
what really happens in terms of speaking
engagements I think they could probably
make maybe 100 to 200 thousand together
even more Harry and Megan both come into
this new phase of royal life with a
stockpile of money
Harry has an estimated personal wealth
of nearly 40 million dollars
Megan meanwhile entered into the
marriage with an estimated net worth of
5 million whoa the late night host had
other suggestions for income she's an
actress this means Megan Markel can go
back to suits and Harry can sell them at
Men's Wearhouse Harry can just join the
cost of Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
yeah
but the best celebrity reaction if I
were Megan Marco and I am that goes to
Amy Schumer who posted this photo with
the caption
Chris and I are formally stepping down
from our royal duties we appreciate your
support now the question is did all this
happen because of Megan or has Harry
always wanted out he resented being a
royal of Prince Harry himself has
admitted there are times in his life
when he wished he hadn't been born a
prince should just sit even when he was
a child the spare air was always a rebel
admitting to underage drinking and
smoking pot or let myself down at my
farm town and all the people done but
then there should be a certain amount of
primacy that one should explain Prince
Harry once said to me he asked me what's
it like to take the tube and that said
so much to me that was a person who just
wanted to experience ordinary life being
normal so how much of this is Megan's
influence I think I think Megan has
boosted Harry's confidence and in Megan
he has found that partner he has found
his equal if he could have stepped down
as the senior royal some time back I
think he probably would have done but he
didn't have he didn't have the
confidence or the strength to do that of
course Harry learned a lot by watching
his mom Princess Diana and her own
struggles with royal life no matter was
despite all of the difficulties of
growing up in that limelight and on that
stage she was going to ensure that both
of us had as normal life as possible I
think there's probably a bit of her that
was recognized that rebellious streak
and in her youngest son but I think she
would be devastated by the fallout and
the rift between the two brothers
[Music]